une coalition de groupe environnementaux
demande à l'Office de protection du
consommateur d'imposer une amende de
100000 dollars à l'encontre d'énergie on
en parlait d'ailleurs mardi à l'émission
C'est la coalition sortons le gaz formé
d'équitter de Greenpeace de
l'Association des médecins pour
l'environnement qui accuse énergie de
représentation fausse ou trompeuse sur
le gaz naturel renouvelable des clients
acceptent de payer plus cher pour
obtenir du gaz naturel de source
renouvelable mais il recevrait en fait
du gaz naturel régulier d'origine
fossile comme les autres clients au
total c'est 1484 clients résidentiels et
industriels qui seraient l'aisé avec
nous ce soir Stéphanie Trudeau
vice-présidente exécutive pour le Québec
chez NRJ bonsoir madame Trudeau vous
vous contestez ces accusations vous
dites que ce n'est pas vrai pourquoi
mais tout à fait ce qu'il nous reproche
en fait si j'ai bien compris c'est
d'utiliser le mot consommer lorsque l'on
parle de gaz naturel renouvelable
pourtant consommer c'est pas un mot
marketing tel qu'il nous accuse c'est un
mot qui apparaît à nos conditions de
service si vulgarise c'est le mot qui
nous est autorisé par notre régulateur
la Régie de l'énergie pour utiliser
lorsqu'un client achète du gaz naturel
c'est un terme qui a été discuté en
audience devant la Régie ou plusieurs de
ces groupes d'ailleurs sont intervenants
et ne se sont jamais opposés au terme
consommé on va on va décrypter tout ça
sur votre site web c'est écrit par
exemple on va sur la page du site web de
Gaz Métro de d'énergie faites un geste
concret pour la planète en choisissant
le gaz naturel renouvelable ensuite
c'est écrit demande d'achat vous
souhaitez passer au gaz naturel
renouvelables soumettre une demande et
une fois qu'on a cliqué c'est écrit
quand on écrit en savoir plus on arrive
à une section personnalisée votre
consommation selon vos valeurs trois
propositions dont la proposition 100%
convertissez 100% de votre consommation
annuelle de gaz naturel
ose d'environ 45 dollars 50 par mois la
personne qui fait ça aura t-elle 100% de
gaz naturel renouvelables il y aura 100%
de gaz naturel renouvelables que lui
sera attribué contractuellement c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne dans le monde
entier au Québec on est moins habitué
mais que ça soit pour un réseau gazier
ou électrique si on veut
s'approvisionner en électricité verte
disons qu'on est dans un état qui est à
25 % d'énergie verte ils vont pas bâtir
deux réseaux de transmission et
distribution électrique et si vous
décidez de payer pour avoir de l'éolien
vous allez recevoir le même électron
c'est des c'est interchangeable donc
c'est comme ça au Québec je peux
comprendre ça me surprend mais qu'on
comprenne moins parce qu'on est moins
habitué mais ce que l'on fait c'est ce
qui se fait à travers le monde entier
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne est-ce
que vous dites là pourquoi vous le dites
pas parce que c'est écrit clairement
votre consommation
convertissez 100% de votre consommation
annuelle de gaz naturel puis vous allez
payer 45 dollars 50 par mois pourquoi
vous l'expliquez pas installer lui elle
est liée à attribuée pardon et donc même
si les gens ont un crédit de du système
de performance qu'on appelle communément
le SPEN donc ils ont droit de dire
qu'ils consomment 100%
d'énergie renouvelable c'est un fait
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne ils ont
pas un tuyau qui
sont dédié bien sûr on n'a pas dédoubler
toutes les
personnes qui choisit cette option 100%
45 dollars 50 par mois
reçoit quelle part d'énergie
renouvelable et d'énergie fossile la
consommation qui passe dans son tuyau
c'est la même consommation que les
autres mais elle a le droit de mettre
sur son bilan qu'elle consomme 100%
d'énergie renouvelable comme je vous dis
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne partout
mais physiquement c'est sûr que c'est
combien physiquement dans le réel
présentement c'est 1% l'an prochain 2 ça
soit 5% à 20-25 et 10% à 20 ans donc
cette personne qui choisit 100% qui fait
45 dollars 50 de plus par mois reçoit en
principe 1% d'énergie renouvelable et
99% d'énergie fossile c'est ça c'est ce
qui va rentrer dans son tuyau mais elle
a le droit de dire qu'elle est
complètement carbonate c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne partout comme je vous
dis parce que
il y a des gens qui ont l'impression
qu'ils ont choisi de l'énergie
renouvelable c'est de l'énergie logiciel
qui rentre dans leur maison pour 45
dollars 50 de plus par mois je comprends
mais nous nos clients à la plupart hier
il y en a qui ont réagissent sur les
réseaux sociaux nous on a très bien
compris c'est écrit sur votre site web
c'est écrit dans vos conditions de
service on a publié des vidéos depuis 5
ans qui explique que cette
interchangeable que je voudrais que tu
sois le voisin du site d'injection pour
dire que tu consommes je veux dire c'est
comme ça pour tous types d'énergie c'est
un fluide qui passe et donc il faut que
tu sois à côté du site c'est pas tout le
monde peut mettre à côté de Warwick
c'est juste physiquement il faudrait
mettre un bon français un GPS là sur sur
tout ça c'est impossible je serai
impossible de consommer physique que
votre communication devrait être plus
claire pour que les gens comprennent
mieux y compris visiblement il y a une
partie qui semble avoir mal compris on
va faire plus de pédagogie mais nous de
nous accuser qu'on a voulu tromper la
population monsieur Fillon s'il y a une
entreprise qui est transparente comme je
vous dis on en parle depuis des années
dans tous les entrevues qu'on donne on a
des vidéos c'est la deuxième question en
ordre notre site Web comment ça
fonctionne est-ce que je vais recevoir
donc vraiment on sait jamais caché de
rien et donc il faut qu'on soit plus
pédagogue on le fera parce
qu'effectivement on réalise cette
semaine que peut-être au Québec on est
moins habitué à cette notion-là alors
que en France aux États-Unis sont très
très habitués avec cette notion là c'est
à dire je préfère les mots parce que je
pense que les gens savent parler
Français comprennent le français je
comprends le français aussi quand on dit
demande d'achat vous souhaitez passer au
gaz naturel renouvelable soumettre une
demande
personnaliser votre consommation et
convertissez 100% de votre consommation
annuelle de gaz naturel
je sais pas là mais j'ai de la
difficulté à comprendre que c'est pas du
gaz naturel renouvelable que je vais
recevoir pour eux elle aurait attribué
c'est tout un processus qui est audité
et ils ont le crédit de carbone et cette
molécule-là elle est injectée verte
parce qu'elle l'ont acheté donc elle
aurait attribué c'est le temps que tu
utilises à travers le monde on utilise
ça le mot consommation et comme je vous
dis c'est pas un mot qu'on inventé c'est
un mot qui a été autorisé par le
régulateur est-ce que vous communiquez
pas trop rapidement chez NRJ sur le gaz
naturel renouvelable dans la mesure où
c'est moins de 1% de gaz naturel
renouvelable et 99% de gaz facile est-ce
que vous allez pas trouver dans votre
dans vos promotions votre marketing à
parler de gaz naturel renouvelable au
contraire parce qu'on l'a pas au moment
où on se parle tout vendu notre 1% il
reste encore un inventaire donc il faut
en parler pour qu'on trouve prenant pour
le 2% pour le 5% pour la 10%, c'est
quelque chose qui se bâtit on a de la
pédagogie à faire donc au contraire moi
je pense qu'on devrait en parler
davantage on n'a jamais vous regardez
toutes nos communications on n'a jamais
laissé sous-entendre qu'on avait plus
qu'on avait dans notre réseau
Québec va vous imposer vous impose en
fait de distribuer au moins 10% de gaz
naturel renouvelables en 2030 est-ce que
vous allez l'atteindre c'est un minimum
on est très content de cette
réglementation là vous êtes à 1% oui on
a on se parle de contracter on a 5 %
donc on va être là pour 20-25 pour
l'objectif de 5 et 7 communication qui
suscite des questions qui suscitent une
plainte également vous allez l'améliorer
on va faire plus de pédagogie
aujourd'hui même on envoyait un courriel
à l'ensemble de nos clients avec la
vidéo qui explique très bien qui était
déjà disponible on leur renvoya tous nos
clients et on va continuer à expliquer
si c'est pas c'est clair on va expliquer
on va faire plus de pédagogie mais vous
l'avez envoyé en anglais d'abord ce
matin mais c'était une erreur technique
c'est une erreur technique vous l'avez
fait quelques heures plus tard en
français
c'est dommage que ce soit arrivé
aujourd'hui on s'en excuser tout de
suite parfait madame trudot merci
beaucoup merci monsieur
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI